the interesting thing about these voices
it's that the voices are dubbed so here
you've got a movie about dubbing voices
and let me just follow me on this so if
you want to know what Jean Hagen's real
speaking voice is it is the voice that
Debbie Reynolds Reynolds is supposedly
dubbing Jean Hagen's voice that's
actually Jean Hagen's real voice so when
she says until the stars turn cold
that's Jean Hagen not Debbie Reynolds
when she sings that number that's
actually a woman named Betty noise who's
dubbing for Debbie's so it gets quite
complicated now I just wanted to tell
you you know I wanted to tell you two
things one the production records we're
very fortunate most of the records of
these movies were all destroyed MGM
threw away most of their records cut got
rid of costumes photographs but the
Arthur freed collection is over at USC
and I've spent a lot of years there and
this is just to give you an example of
the production notes the details this is
on this was shot July 19 1951 it was a
Thursday director's rehearsing boom
moves with dance ins and setting new
marks for camera 917 to 925 rehearse
with principals to playback 925 to 927
Kelly complete final wardrobe 927 to 929
star train for scene 929 to 932 Kelley
changing pants due to loose cuff 932 to
934 put sawdust in puddle for effect 934
to 936 shoot one take 935 to 948 set a
de drainpipe sweep excess water off
streets 948 to 956
replace practical light which failed
shoot a 8 takes one no good for camera 2
3 4 6 no good for action so that's every
minute of every day of the shooting so